I really love your idea of this that an
entrepreneur by definition must be
unreasonable must be unreasonable in
their expectations their drive and their
idealism the entrepreneurial Adventure
is romanticized to your point it's it's
a slog and I think people who truly live
that lifestyle
you know there's a grit and a stupidity
to it
I think that you know the beauty of
Entrepreneurship is that you don't have
to have the right answer like if you
have a big idea and you have enthusiasm
and you start sharing it with people
this is my experience they'll tell you
where you're wrong they'll tell you how
to refine it and you know the job is
just to punch through wall after wall
for a decade that's the job it's not
sexy it's so romanticized you know in
media and in television but the reality
is is that you just have to be willing
to be deeply responsive and to you know
take a lot of shrapnel on your way up
the mountain